- Adam is the most excited about this episode.
In fact, it was his idea, so toast!
- That's right.
We were pretty excited to try
a bunch of bread for an episode.
Adam had the brilliant idea
of looking at bread world through the ship of toast.
So today, not only are we going to three restaurants,
but we're also going to a couple of bakeries.
This is really going to be a jam-packed episode.
- Wow.
Today on Worth It,
we're gonna be trying three awesome toast dishes
at three drastically,
wait, not so drastically different price points,
to find which one is the most worth it at its price.
FYI, the toast we're doing, it's not your average toast.
It's not your side toast, this toast is entree toast.
You ready?
- Toast me.
(whimsical music)
^- I'm Jessica Koslow.
^We're here at Sqirl in Silver Lakes.
Today we're trying our ricotta toast,
the poster child of sweet food here at Sqirl.
Sqirl started in 2011 as a jam company,
and when we started, we really only had this space here.
So we were doing pretty much everything on toast.
All the jams are made here, fresh in copper pans.
It is all labor, the jams are made by hand,
the ricotta, and all of these things.
The only thing that's not is the bread
because we don't have the space,
and that is why we find really special producers
like Oven Grandmas for our whitefish tartine.
We use Clark Street Baguettes for
this chickpea dish that has basically
a sword where we cut the baguette from tip to tail.
For the ricotta toast, we use a fluffy brioche
that we get from Farmshop.
- [Anthony] Brioche has actually pretty simple ingredients.
It has flour, yeast, salt, sugar
^and then the enrichment part, there's milk,
there's eggs, and there's butter.
We are using California butter.
It's high butter fat, so you're looking at
like, 80 percent. We're also using
California cage-free eggs, and we will shape it,
it will go into the pre-sprayed pans
that we've got ready to go, our loaf pans,
where you have a dome-top
which is what the ones we're making for Sqirl.
- And the challenge of making the round-top brioche
versus the flat pullman loaves
It's the mixing process. So if the mixing
isn't done enough, then you're gonna have gaps.
And depending on how the bread proofs, you might have holes.
It's a different game in a flat-base brioche.
- [Voiceover] And then, it is packed early in the morning.
And then it'll get shipped.
- [Jessica] Cut size is pretty thick.
We roll it on a butter wheel, so we butter it on both sides,
and then we put into a panini press.
It's a flat panini press on both sides,
so it's warm, it's griddled, and then
we let it rest for a second, we put the ricotta on.
We make it from Straus Organic Cream.
We strain it, we add about 90 percent cream
by weight back into the ricotta, and we whip it by hand.
And so it is a fluffy type of ricotta.
A lot of times people want a rainbow,
so they get three flavors of jam.
It does rotate with the seasons, so right now
we'll do blueberry rhubarb, raspberry cardamom,
strawberry rose geranium. We finish it
with a squeeze of fresh lemon juice,
and a sprinkle of Maldon sea salt.
- [Steven] So, at Farmshop,
they were saying you're the only one
who doesn't have the flat top bread, why?
- [Jessica] It looks like a mushroom, it's really fun.
You know, if you're paying eight dollars
for a ricotta toast, it better look fun
and it better look ridiculous, and big,
and that's exactly what it does.
- So first of all, cheers, this is a
- Tumeric Tonic.
That's nice.
- Is it ginger? Oh, it's so good.
- Tumeric.
- [Andrew] Look at this toast.
- Whoa, I just got a big whiff of the jam.
- Yeah, this is beyond toast.
This is my actual face, look at the scale.
Alright, shall I cut you a little cube?
- Please.
- [Steven] Whoa. I will say I've never seen
ricotta presented in this fashion.
- Toast.
Nailed it.
Oh my god.
- Of all of the elements of this toast,
the toast is really just the presenter here.
- Uh huh.
- Like, it's amazing, it's doing its job.
The ricotta is insane, it's so
it's whipped so lightly,
- Yes.
- and it's cheese.
- Okay, next jam.
That jam.
This is a jam story.
- Yes.
- This is like, when you're reading Red Riding Hood,
and you think it's about a little girl,
but really it's about a bad-ass wolf.
- It's like the best parts of a jam sandwich
that I had, and french toast,
and cake.
But light, like whipped cream.
Mix that in a bottle, and you got ricotta toast!
Look at the toast, I love the edges of toast.
You get the crust.
- The crust is a must. Super delicious.
- It's Adam's turn.
^- That is so good.
Ricotta toast.
- On brioche.
- With jam.
- At Sqirl Cafe.
- Is it called Sqirl Cafe?
I don't know, but I'm really into this,
like, back-and-forth thing,
where we just build a sentence together.
I
- Love
- Toast!
- Boom. We're here in
- Koreatown
And we're going to a restaurant
called Here's Looking at You.
Whoa, did you look at me right when I said that?
- I thought I was gonna have to finish part of the
- Oh, my bad. Here's looking at--
- You.
- There we go, gonna have some pâté, some cheese
- A savory toast, that's better than most.
(smooth jazz music)
- [Jonathan] I'm Jonathan Whitener,
I'm the chef owner of Here's Looking at You,
and we're gonna try chicken liver mousse
and stracciatella cheese today.
- What kind of establishment is Here's Looking at You?
- Well, we're like a progressive
kinda Southern California restaurant.
The repertoire is French at heart,
but executed with all types of different cultures.
- When did toast become, like a meal?
- Good bread is the vessel for everything
that you're trying to make. And it wasn't
until I met Andy from Bub and Grandma's,
our signature dishes involve Bub's bread.
It's such a quintessential part of the restaurant.
His bread has a perfect balance of texture and flavor.
The aeration of it, and the fact he cooks
with passion that implements on the food.
- [Andy] Part of our thing is creating
a happy place to work that doesn't
push people away from their families and friends,
and it translates into the products that come out the door.
We use higher percentage whole grain
than most other bakers in town.
I feel like there's more flavor in the whole grains
and it helps to move people more towards real bread
as oppose to chemically engineered bread.
It's a three day process, basically.
We mix weighed out bins, they start fermenting.
Throughout the three hour bulk fermentation,
we do folds on the dough to build strength
These keep building a scaffold inside that
holds in all those CO2 bubbles,
so that it doesn't collapse in the oven.
Shaping it into a bowl,
goes in the baskets, goes in the walk-in,
come in the next morning, straight out of the baskets
they flip onto the loader, and then they bake.
Max is gonna score these because when we do our final shape,
the exterior of the loaves are made strong enough
to hold the thing up. So now we want to
actually release that tension so that they can rise
to their fullest potential in the oven.
Caring is number one, like I'm just a really anxious person
and if things aren't perfect, they need to be.
Which these guys do, it's personal, like
especially when you get up early in the morning like this
and sacrifice part of your normal life
to come work here, you have to care.
- This bread is epic. You know, we hit it up
with a lot of olive oil to help get a really good char on it
and just slap it on the grill,
We have a wood burning grill, burns at like, 700 degrees.
A lot of our clients are like
is it supposed to be burnt like this?
and it's like yeah.
(laughs)
A lot of people don't realize that burning stuff
like that and not even smoking is a technique of cooking.
The chicken liver mousse we use
is really high quality Jidori chicken livers.
I actually take my maple syrup and smoke it
and then we add that to the liver.
We serve it with a side of Bub's bread,
and then pickled pupiras
which are like Spanish basque peppers.
- [Steven] Alright, we got this beautiful rosé,
- [Andrew] We do.
- [Steven] Which I know you love the color of.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
(glasses clink)
So this is our first build your own toast segment.
You get to control your flavors a little bit more.
Do you want to try the bread on its own?
- I actually really do.
Cause' he was really talking up Andy's bread.
Cheers, Toast.
(laughs)
- That was so awkward.
(mellow music)
Oh yeah.
Already.
- Look at the aeration on that bread inside, it's just like
- Okay, you're just saying aeration
cause' you heard the chef say aeration.
- Look.
- Look at the texture, yeah, look at the bread.
Alright, here it comes.
You wanna get that nice and shmeared on.
(bread crackles)
- Whoa.
- Yeah.
- I used to think that trains were the perfect vehicle.
No, bread is the perfect vehicle of flavor.
It almost tastes aged.
- Yeah.
(clicks tongue)
- Yeah, let me try that.
- [Jonathan] The strat cheese is a cheese
that we get from Gioia, it's a local producer here.
We make it as kind of like a Japanese pesto
so we use Japanese parsley, Shingiku,
which is a chrysanthemum leaf, corilla, some cilantro,
and then yuzu kosho, and mix that all together
like a pretty smooth pesto, put that on top of the cheese,
add toasted pumpkin seeds on top,
and then serve it with Bub's bread.
^- [Steve] Round two, baby, we got a Chardonnay, also bubbly.
- Do you know any foreign language toasts?
- Yeah, in like, Korean we go jjan.
In Chinese, it's "gānbēi."
- Gānbēi.
In Ukrainian it's "nazdorovje."
- Ooh. I like that. How do you say that?
Naz-ee-uh-ro-ga?
- Naz-dah-rov-ee-uh
- Naz-duh-rov-ah
- You know what? Let's eat some toast.
- So now we've upgraded to a deeper vessel.
Hell yeah, we got soft cheese.
That is the realm I like to live in.
- [Steve] God, see, that's what you want in cheese.
A little creamy, a little messy
- A little stringy, but it's a cool cheese.
Don't think this is hot and melty.
- Uh-uh, toast.
(bread crackles)
That's the one.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna cry, it's so good.
- This tastes like, both the milk fresh from the cow,
and the grass that the cow was standing on.
In a very delicious way, not a gross way.
- Mm-hm.
- I think the amount the amount of time it takes to chew
a piece of bread really says something about how good it is.
- Here's the thing, I've had good bread before,
but I didn't realize that bread could be like,
this luxurious, like this epic.
- You take it for granted, for sure.
- You gotta get in here, Adam.
- Yeah, Adam, you gotta get in here.
(bread crackles)
Premium ice cream, here's to eating toast.
- Yo, that toast was crazy, that was delicious.
- Yeah, it was crazy delicious.
- Alright, where are we goin' next, Andrew?
- We're going to San Francisco
to have some twenty dollar toast.
- San Francisco?
- Yeah. To not have toast,
but to have a tartine, which is toast.
- Which is toast, that's toast right?
Well... is it toast?
- It's toast as we're choosing to call toast.
^(smooth jazz music)
^- Hi, I'm Dominique Crenn, and this is one of my restaurant
called Petit Crenn, it's a very casual French bistro,
it's an homage to my mother and my grandmother
cooking from Brittany, the focus here
is just vegetable and seafood, there is no meat.
- You have another restaurant here in San Francisco.
- Yes, I do have and that's the restaurant
that's kind of my baby, Atelier Crenn.
And this is a dish that's kind of a take
on dish that I used to do at Atelier Crenn
on the tasting menu called the Walk in the Forest.
I used to go to the forest with my dad often,
and this is the blackberry and mushroom
and wetness outside, and that smell,
and that funkiness, so it's kind of a take
on a hey, let's do a mushroom tartine here,
and how you can bring the mushroom
to the next level without killing it.
You take the bread, grill it on the grill.
We get different type of mushroom,
each is very to the season.
Sauté the mushroom with a little bit of butter,
a little bit of olive oil,
they glaze them with cherry vinegar.
What we want to achieve is to glaze the mushroom
with the butter and just make them
like just a little bit of acidic or so with the vinegar.
You have to taste your food.
You have to know what you're putting on the plate.
You have to understand the balance.
You know, it's very important.
We made Espelette mayonnaise,
There's a lot of umami and there's a lot of fat in that dish
so you want to cut that with a bit
of cornichon, elephant garlic, different type of herb,
finish with a little bit of seas salt,
turn it, eat it, and go to sleep.
When you have a bread and you know
there is a lot of work behind it,
then you know it's delicious.
Less is more, less is always more, I think so.
- [Steven] Yeah.
- [Dominique] What do I know.
- Toast.
(glasses clink)
- Cheers.
(soothing music)
- Have you ever seen a funner color?
- This is natural.
- It is.
- And beautiful-tasting.
- Speaking of beautiful, look at that.
I'll split the toast?
- Please... part the forest.
Cheers, toast.
- Toast.
Oh my god.
I can't, I have no words.
- It's interesting because mushroom
is far from the predominant flavor on this tartine.
It's there, and it's delicious,
but the balance of little acidic things
- Yes, totally perfect.
- This is extremely delicious.
I think more than anything, I'm devastated
by things that I've worked so much harder and longer on
that didn't taste nearly as good.
- Yeah, less is more, though.
- It is.
- Less is more.
- If you know how to do it.
- Right, right, right.
- What a toasty episode we just had.
- But I'm chilly.
- Hey, don't get jelly of my Worth It Winner,
because my Worth It Winner
on this very special episode is Sqirl.
- Whoa.
- Yeah, that was a very Worth It piece of toast, why?
Three kinds of very special jelly,
and a whipped ricotta on a sick brioche?
Come on, that's very Worth It.
- Yeah, I mean, wow, I can't believe
you're choosing that as your Worth It Winner.
- Believe it.
- My Worth It Winner... ugh
wait, can Adam, can you go first please?
- Adam, who's your Worth It Winner?
Adam said Here's Looking at You.
Adam says the liver mousse, whoa.
- Alright so, yeah, Petit Crenn is my Worth It Winner.
That was, it was delicious.
- That's a good choice,
That is a very strong toast game
coming out of Petit Crenn.
- But I don't feel good saying it
because they were all so good.
- Did you know that tip was included for that tartine?
- Oh yeah, that does it for me, then.
- Yeah, tip included?
- Yeah, there we go.
- Done.
- That was a very fun episode.
Not a crazy high price point,
but for a food like toast, still pretty interesting.
You saw a couple bakeries, you saw some bread get baked,
you saw some toast get toasted.
Come on, it was a great time we just had together, so
- All of us.
- You,
- We'll be back next week.
- me, Adam, and all of y'all.
- Toast.
- [Voiceover] Oh yes!